[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen oder mittag
oder abend oder nachts oder keine ahnung
was gerade ist erwartet uns allerdings
auf jeden fall hier in unserer kleinen
süßen minecraft welt bzw gerade sogar
hier in unserem kleinen süßen bunker und
wir sehen auch schon in der letzten
folge aber das ganze jahr angepflanzt
und seit der letzten folge ist hier
einige schon so ein bisschen gewachsen
ich habe gehört dass palucca valencia
oben geklettert deswegen schauen wir mal
direkt proben nach wir haben nacht
ich weiß das habe ich gesehen wir müssen
jetzt auf jeden fall mal eben fix
schlafengehen ich hoffe dass ich es
schaffe zum bett zu kommen ohne dass
mich irgendwelche monster entdecken das
hat
nicht geklappt
jetzt muss das glaube ich klappen
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde jetzt sollte es
endlich klappen und wir können entspannt
jetzt kann ich auf jeden fall sagen dass
uns ein wunderschöner morgen hier in
unserer kleinen süßen minecraft der
waadt ist es wirklich wundervoll wie
alles hier aussieht finde ich möchte
eigentlich gar nicht dass dieses projekt
eine dabei ich freue mich auch schon
wieder extrem kreislauf staffel 2
demnächst dann irgendwann die sache ist
allerdings und das habe ich in der
letzten episode schon angekündigt ich
brauch erst mal ganz kurz dem webstuhl
iab gebraucht wir erst mal endlich nicht
mehr ich habe heute mir vorgenommen eine
menge auf kommentare einzugehen da hier
ja immer so aktiv sein und mir so viele
sachen schreibt dachte ich mir
orientiere ich mich mal so ein bisschen
und ihr seht auch schon ich habe gerade
meine axt und meine spitzhacke unten
reingeschmissen das
ja denn ich habe 49 diamanten und damit
kommen auch schon zum ersten kommentar
die mir geschrieben wurde denn da wurde
mir gesagt du kannst 49 diamanten wo
willst du damit hin macht ihr doch
einfach mal diamantwerkzeuge geht alles
soll die schneller die sachen halten
deutlich länger du musst dir nicht mehr
so oft alles neu machen und du kannst
die diamanten eh nicht mehr los werden
bis das projekt endet wir haben nur noch
ein paar folgen vor uns irgendwie
erfolgen oder zwölf folgen von daher
kann ich mir gerne alles hier aus
diamanten machen wir haben das schwert
mit schärfen drei verzaubert den boden
haben ja auch mehr können uns aus dem
diamanten gerade einfach nicht machen
deswegen die stärke auch mal ganz kurz
herein ich muss mir ganz kurz was zu
essen holen dafür werde ich mir jetzt
allerdings auch mal einfach das bohrmehl
nehmen hier oben und das direkt mal auf
unsere kleine farm unten anwenden und
während ich das mache kann ich direkt
zum hallo herr nicht direkt auf den
zweiten kommentar eingehen dem ich mir
für heute vorbereitet habe und zwar
wurde mir geschrieben luca du musst
immer noch das glas in den boden setzen
bei der strandhaus bilder von daher ich
nehme erst mal ganz produziert das
beizen mit beziehungsweise kann ja auch
mal die melonen und kartoffeln hier auf
essen und die kartoffeln dann
theoretisch ja auch endlich mal an
pflanzen und ist aber auch egal ich muss
die kartoffeln auf jeden fall erstmal
braten bevor ich die esse auf jeden fall
möchte ich heute auch selbstverständlich
dass glas bzw den glasboden fertig
machen in der modernen stand haus villa
da hatte ich ja damals gesagt dass mir
dadurch perfekt und die korallenriffe
anschauen können daher greifen wir
natürlich direkt zu unserem schwarzem
glas und bewegen und hier hinten zu
unserer modernen strandhaus villa
während wir natürlich in der modernen
strandhaus villa sind wird auch unser
mops border dort hinten befindet der
sich ja unser skelett des bonner wird
währenddessen natürlich glaube ich
angetrieben oder lädt das doch nicht so
weit ich weiß es nicht können uns auf
jeden fall gleich mal anschauen das wird
nämlich auch ohne den kommentare
geschrieben luca besorgt wird wieder ein
paar level ich weiß nicht wofür ich
diese level benötige weil ich 34 level
habe also keinen plan warum
ungebetene gäste sind da wecken wir
haben eigentlich
also hier ist alles ausgeleuchtet unsere
toilette dann werde ich echt sehr stolz
darauf die sache ist allerdings dass wir
uns hier gar nicht auf oben
konzentrieren wollen wir haben heute
genug zu tun sondern ich möchte hier
erst mal jetzt irgendwo einen glasboden
machen und ich weiß nicht genau wo ich
den machen möchte weil das ding
es ist in dem moderne strandhaus will
auch ein gutes wetter ich probier mal ob
das klappt wenn ich mich einfach im bett
lege dass wir das dadurch überspringen
können so
krass aber ich es doch richtig in
erinnerung deswegen haben wir jetzt
nämlich einen neuen tag und sie haben
auch den regen weg perfekt auch das
klima hier oben schlafen wieder ein kuli
die sache ist allerdings dass ich jetzt
erst mal kurz gucken wollte wo wir das
überhaupt machen mit der modernen
strandhaus bilder also hier erst mal so
ein bisschen rum schwimmen wir haben
hier auf jeden fall korallenriffe und
wenn ich das hier machen würde dann
müsste ich hier nach oben gehen schau
mal kurz so also es wäre war sie direkt
unter der treppe das könnte man
theoretisch sogar machen da habe ich
gerade den der den bambus ziel glauben
stehen genau das zuckerrohr ich weiß
nicht wie es sein wird wenn ich hier das
ganze abbaue und darunter jetzt auch ich
habe drei
etagen sogar
weil die sache ist halt dass ich dann ja
dem glasboden so groß machen muss dass
man nicht mehr die drei blöcke daneben
sieht ich kann ja mal dass theoretisch
an einer stelle ganz kurz probieren da
müsste ich allerdings hier natürlich
drei blöcke runtergehen und wisst ihr
den job jetzt abbauen wenn ich jetzt
eine glasglocke hinsetzen sieht das hat
richtig blöde aus deswegen muss ich
eigentlich größer machen ich kann es
jetzt einfach mal probieren ich werd
jetzt auch einfach mal machen die sache
ist das projekt nicht mehr lang und das
habe ich mir vorgenommen von der egal
wie es aussieht ich mache das jetzt also
hier vorne drumherum diese blöcke
natürlich auch noch mal kurz abbauen
sagt zack zack und bumm und bahn und
wenn ich jetzt hier das schwarze glas
brandsätze sieht das ganze halt so aus
der blogger müssen zu viel zeit es ist
nicht so geil wie ich es mir vorgestellt
habe aber wir können zumindest runter
gucken ich nehme noch mal ganz kurz die
blöcke da eben weg dass sie nicht die
ganze zeit da oben hoch schwimmen von
unten sie ist glaube ich dann geile aus
als von oben haben wir das nehme ich
jetzt alles hier so gut jetzt auch nicht
so gut aus ich habe jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz alle blöcke 1 und schwimmen
dann auch mal eben kurz rüber zu unserer
skelett farm da hab ich euch den
kommentar ja vorhin schon eingeblendet
da wurde mir nämlich gesagt luca wurde
mal wieder ein paar level schmeißt mal
wieder die farben hier vorne an die
sache ist wirklich allerdings dass sich
ja eigentlich genügend level habe ich
habe 34 stück ich weiß nicht was ich
noch verzaubern kann ich kann hier
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was drauf
verzaubern wird mir auch geschrieben
luca mach doch mal auf deine schuhe
bitte feder fall drauf weil man im ende
immer krass hoch geschleudert wird vom
drachen wir sind keine skelette
aber eine menge pfeile
ich glaub ich muss warten hier bis die
kommende
baumeister eine stunde später
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich brauch keine
level mehr also danke wir auf jeden fall
auch für den kommentar und diese
funktioniert ja auch allerdings müssen
wir dann halt hier die ganze zeit warten
bis die teile hier hoch geschleudert
werden dann nach vorne wieder runter
fallen und
das kann ich nur mal eben ganz einmal
eben töten aber er wird ja auch unten
wie wenig leer will ich eigentlich nur
dadurch bekommen sonst
müsste ich jetzt wirklich ziemlich lange
stehen als ich das letzte mal gemacht
habe habe ich ja nicht einfach
hingestellt dann bin ich dass ich in die
küche gegangen was zu essen gemacht
finden und danach standen erhalten 30
blätter oder so von daher macht das dann
auf jeden fall sinn die sache ist
allerdings dass sie jetzt gerade für
mich halt null komma null sind macht von
daher konzentrieren sich auf diesen
kommentar hier da wo mich geschrieben
ducati muss endlich einmal deinen freund
da holen wird ein schweinchen will ja
die ganze zeit haben papa das ergebnis
sogar mädchen eigentlich möchte auf
jeden fall einen freund haben und da
können wir am liebsten dann auch
schorsch holen denn aus der serie pepper
potts das ist papa und dass es ihr
bruder schorsch
oh
mein gott okay da habe ich noch eine
karotte ich habe gerade extra unten
geguckt und ich habe hier die teile
abgebaut aber das war kartoffeln
angebaut wurden ich dachte gerade ich
habe keine karte mehr aber einer habe
ich zum glück noch und damit können wir
nun ein schweinchen vom festland holen
beziehungsweise werde ich zuallererst
mal ganz kurz die tür abbauen und hier
vorne raus lotsen also papa komm mir
bitte hinterher der hat sich ja
irgendwie rhein verlaufen und was sich
auch in den kommentaren gelesen habe ich
weiß allerdings nicht ob ich den
kommentar zu finden werde im schnitt die
sache war allerdings dass man da auf
jeden fall gesagt wurde luca dort ja
noch ein schaf auf der insel ich glaube
dass sitzt hier vorne irgendwo fest das
hat die irgendwer in irgend einer szene
am fenster gesehen hier vorne also ich
weiß ich habe mich da verarscht
ja da bist du dann aber selbst schuld
also auch für den idioten hier müssen
wir ganz kurz die tür ausbauen ich habe
jetzt leider kein weizen dabei das
könnte ich mir aber ganz kurz mal hier
vorne holen das hier ist ja schon
ausgewachsen das ding deswegen nehmen
wir auch die ganz kurz in die hand und
holen unser schiffchen hier vorne aus up
effekt jetzt hat es doch schon geschafft
dann können wir auch hier vorne die tür
wieder einsetzen wir müssen auch
eigentlich shui hier vorne mal so ein
bisschen reparieren das schäfchen kommt
allerdings erst mal wieder zurück mit
natürlich auf unsere insel hat sich das
ein bisschen verlaufen es ist so ein
bisschen sonne insel reparatur folge
heute ohne dass wir die insel reparieren
sondern eigentlich nur die leute die auf
der insel wohnen und daher das che
findet wieder am start pepper ist wieder
im freien wir nehmen ganz kurz uns ein
bisschen eisen laufen dame darüber zu
tui und müssen dann mit unserer karotte
rüber aufs festland um ein schweinchen
freund zu holen das letzte was ich dann
für die heutige episode noch vorhabe wo
ist ein tui-sprecher
auch die ganze zeit immer ihnen worum
sie nicht er ist jetzt gestorben während
ich jetzt kurz weg weisen holen
na da was sagt man da
sagt man nicht aber ich traue mich
stress zu machen ich muss mal ganz kurz
in mein brot flecken damit ich wieder
vernünftig laufen kann perfekte habe ich
die treppen hoch gemacht und noch kein
brötchen kam und jetzt benötigen wir
eigentlich nur noch die karotte und
bewegen uns in ein kart
ja okay gut dann kommt da natürlich mit
aufs festland ich wollte eigentlich erst
wieder euch einblenden wenn ich da
hinten bin allerdings der sich irgendwie
eingesetzt von der herkommen bruder
wahllos können eine kleine reise zack
zack zack und jetzt müsste er eigentlich
einen anspruch bekommen
darin könnten natürlich liegen
nachrichtlich noch eine aktivierung
schiene idiot main ev schon war die
aktivierung schiene mal ganz kurz gegen
eine antriebs schiene dann sollte das
aufpassen ich weiß ich hab da noch eine
fackel stand sonst nämlich
sicherheitshalber auch noch mal eine mit
und ich nehme auch ein namensschild mit
was ich ganz kurz schon mal zu shorts
umwandeln kann damit wenn ich ein
schweinchen finde ich auch direkt weiß
dass ich das an mitnehmen möchte und
dass er auch den namen schorsch trägt
also hier einmal ganz kurz schorsch
draufschreiben zeit haben wir das auf
jeden fall am start die sonne da hinten
geht auch schon wieder so langsam unter
von daher werde ich jetzt auch immer
ganz fix meiner items sortieren und mich
danach erst aufs festland bewegen auch
noch mal hier unten im bunker
beziehungsweise bei unserer untergrund
fahren alle weizen sachen mal ab wo die
noch nicht so krass gewachsen sind aus
irgendeinem grund und bau der kartoffeln
hin weil ich glaube dass gebratene
kartoffeln mehr leben ausfüllen als
brot würde mir allerdings nicht sicher
also vertraut mit der bitte nicht und
jetzt ist es auch schon so langsam
dunkel von daher können wir uns auf
jeden fall unser bettchen liegen ich
werde mich dafür einfach mal hier oben
reinlegen in unser traumhaus vom beginn
des ganzen projektes damit ging halt
alles los irgendwie werde ich mit
zunehmender dauer bzw mit dem ende was
er immer näher kommt zunehmend
nostalgischer und freue mich irgendwie
darauf dass es zu ändert sich jetzt ist
auch irgendwie in jeder folge ist auch
ein thema das es bald vorbei ist um auch
leider sich das thema so krass und
thematisiere allerdings eher villages
weg
na gut dann fahren wir leider dahin also
hier auf jeden fall die antrieb china
hin die schon mal eben ganz kurz auf das
klappt wir brauchen jetzt zwei mein
cards glaube ich weil wir das schwein
auf jeden fall mitnehmen müssen also das
pferd auf jeden fall und ich fahre nun
auch aus fest dann können wir das andere
karte jetzt mitnehmen ich glaube das
sollte funktionieren perfekt das klappt
auch ja die sache ist es tut mir leid
dass ich das die ganze zeit zum
thematisiere dieses thema ja das projekt
bis bald vorbei und bleibt bekommen wir
die kommentare von wegen einer uns noch
nicht mehr daran dass es bald vorbei ist
aber ich glaube man sollte wirklich gern
mit nach vorfreude darauf zu gehen weil
die letzte folge der extremen lang ich
werde ins ende gehen ich hoffe dass ich
schaffe gegen ihren adretten das dann
noch mal ein schönes ende man sieht die
credits am ende in minecraft und damit
dass dann alles vorbei ihr bekommt einen
download link zu der map liegt
dementsprechend auf den zieht wenn ihr
von vorne anfangen wollte meiner eigenen
welt und seht dann auch endlich mal dass
hier nichts geschieht ist oder irgendwas
mit diamanten die spaziert darüber keine
ahnung was man alles vorgeworfen wurde
allein das dahin gegenwind kam bei
diesem projekt aber wir haben
durchgehalten haben es gemacht ich bin
sehr sehr stolz auf dieses projekt und
ich glaube wirklich und das habe ich ja
gerade schon gesagt
bleib bitte
hier ich glaube man sollte einfach mit
einer gewissen vorfreude erreichen was
ich hier erreichen wollte weiß ich nicht
einmal soll ich mir vor freude in die
letzte folge gehen die folge 100 es
dauert zwar noch zwei drei wochen bis es
soweit ist aber ich freue mich auf jeden
fall auf staffel 2 und ich habe so viele
ideen das wird so geil allein mit mode
und so was ich alles vorhabe hier haben
wir allerdings erst mal ein schweinchen
gefunden und ich werde direkt das
namensschild nehmen und das schweinchen
schorsch nennen jetzt haben wir nämlich
schorsch
ok genau so freundlich wie papa komm mal
kurz mit hier unsere karotte hat mit am
start einmal 40 hochklettern und jetzt
ab ins main hat das hätte ich jetzt gar
nicht gedacht dass das hier so fix geht
dass wir hier direkt und kleine
schweinchen finden allerdings haben wir
damit dann auch schon den vierten der 5
kommentare die ich leute vorbereitet
habe abgehakt wir haben das schweinchen
bereits gefunden wir haben das mit dem
korallenriff glas gemacht auch wenn wir
es schlussendlich ja nicht so toll
hingekriegt haben wie es mir vorgestellt
habe haben es auf jeden fall gemacht ich
habe mit dieser werkzeuge gemacht und
wir waren einem skelett bonner also
jetzt einmal ganz kurz zurück auf die
insel bringen den chip ich mal eben kurz
an das sollte er passen klappen glaube
ich und jetzt schiebe ich mich selber
auch noch mal ganz kurz die eben wieder
zurück auf eine insel setze mich hier
rein und ab geht die fahrt perfekt dann
schauen wir mal ob schorsch und pepper
sich vertragen und kümmern uns dann um
den letzten kommentar nur wenige minuten
später der schorsch es auf der insel
angekommen und wir müssen ihn jetzt
pepper vorstellen ich weiß nicht wo
pepper ist sie ist er ja vorhin noch
irgendwo rumgelaufen und war ohne lange
zeit gefangen unserer kisten krypta spa
und die beiden freuten sie sich an
[Musik]
ich liebe das diese komplette harmonie
hier auf der insel die karotte müssen
wir auf jeden fall gut aufbewahren von
daher pflanzt sich auch die jetzt mal
ganz kurz unten unserem bunker an denn
die karotte benötigen wir ja einfach für
die schweinchen von daher kann ich auch
noch mal ganz wird sie ihm diese beiden
sachen ab und da ist das schon mal
gewachsen hier vorne auch also hier auch
neu anpflanzen hier dann wird
wahrscheinlich die weizenkörner rein und
das weizen packe ich hier vornherein zum
anderen weiß beziehungsweise kann ich
mir auch ganz kurz mit nehmen damit ich
mir daraus noch ein neues brötchen
machen kann kommen wir nun allerdings
meine lieben freunde zu dem letzten
kommentar auf den ich heute eingehen
möchte ich habe ich noch eine menge pole
blöcke da kann ich auch mal eben ganz
kurz abchecken ob meine kartoffeln schon
gebrauchen sind also die sollten denke
ich definitiv schon gebraten sein die
sache ist allerdings ob es eine
ofenkartoffeln oder so ein brot mehr
leben ausfüllt aber das können wir
einfach am ende mal schauen die sache
ist dass wir ich dachte etwas gesagt
aber zum glück nicht wir können die
letzten kommentar und zwar im fehlerfall
auf die schuhe das habe ich ja gerade
schon gesagt benötigen wir wollen uns
der ändert rache in der letzten folge
ein bisschen durch die luft schleudern
wird und deswegen ja wie eine menge fall
schaden kriegen werden außer ich habe
halt fehlerfall 4 auf den schulen also
fehlerfall vier seit die höchste
vertrauen uns gibt dann auch wieder
fällt 2 3 und 1 allerdings weder fall
vier schon extrem geil und ich habe auch
glaube ich genug level dafür deswegen
schauen wir mal wie das ganze hingegen
schutz schutz und schuss sicher
doch wie können es halt wir können das
ganze halt theoretisch wieder mit einem
lesepult villiger machen allerdings hat
unser lesepult villiger also die
bibliotheca halt dann schlussendlich
einfach leider schon eine stufe erreicht
weil ich mit ihm ja schon getrennt habe
ich weiß mir das badfenster macht nicht
die bibliotheken und er hat nur
behutsamkeit und da ich mit ihm schon
getradet habe muss ich ihn jetzt
eigentlich ein bisschen höher treiben
damit erneut race hat ich könnte das
theoretisch mit instructor machen ich
habe allerdings mit mainz marken schon
eine andere idee vor das erfahrt ihr in
der nächsten folge dass suchen wir
nehmen nicht das ende das wirklich
extrem krass also wenn ihr ideen habt
wie ich da eventuelle fehler fall drauf
kriege ohne jetzt irgendwie warten zu
müssen da keine ahnung was den springen
und in die kommentare der zwischenzeit
mag ich die diamant schule erst mal hier
rein und werde nun den ml water back it
sprung jumps probieren benötige dafür
allerdings noch ein bisschen bruchsteine
damit ich mich erst mal ein bisschen
hoch bauen kann ich werde das jetzt
nicht direkt von einer riesigen höhe
probieren von wegen
ja aus 100 blöcken irgendwie wenn ich
hochgeschleudert werde vom ende drachen
weil wenn ich dann jetzt nicht schaffe
im training bin ich halt foto mit meiner
ganzen level weg deswegen nehme ich mir
erstmal überhaupt mein brötchen grün
wahrscheinlich ist dass ein brötchen
luca wir fahren jetzt auf jeden fall
hier zu unserer leuchtturm insel und
werten den ml waterpark het sprung spiel
hier nun mal ganz kurz zum ende der
heutigen episode ein bisschen üben da
werde ich mich mal ganz kurz hier vorne
aussteigen hier direkt mein brötchen
parken und dann hier hoch jumpen und
hier haben wir noch immer die kleine
freie fläche wo wir das ganze ein
bisschen üben können es geht bei dem
sprung da du darum dass ich halt runter
falle von irgendeiner hohen höre ich
glaube das reicht erstmal ohne dass sie
sterben sollte und dann kurz vor dem
aufprall wassereimer setzte
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob
das jetzt an der geringen höhe lag
[Musik]
aber an
mein gott ich bin so ein opfer alter
hip hop 2015 kurz zurück geholt ich
hätte ja niemals gedacht dass ich diesen
ml water bucket sprung direkt zweimal
hintereinander hinkriege also ich glaube
ich muss den gar nicht mehr so krass
üben weil ich das jetzt zweimal schon
geschafft habe klar kann das jetzt nicht
richtig üben das sich irgendwie durch
die luft geschleudert werden und dann
vom ende drachen irgendwie nochmal hoch
geschleudert dann nicht nur gerade
runter falle sondern schräg und so das
kann ich jetzt natürlich nicht richtig
üben die sache ist allerdings dass
dadurch wies üben kann ich es jetzt halt
hingekriegt habe von daher hoffe ich
dass ich das auch in ende dann
schlussendlich im endkampf hinkriegen
werde ich falls sie mal ganz kurz die
eben um unser portal schwert rum ich
weiß auch was das für ein chaos weil
dieses ding zu bauen die folge ging ja
auch so lang dann fahren wir ganz kurz
durch unsere brücke drunter her das habe
auch schon länger nicht mehr gemacht in
den sonnenuntergang ein kind mit unserer
trauer insel beziehungsweise eigentlich
tier insel trauer in salz eigentlichen
zu trauriger name und parken das mädchen
dann selbstverständlich fordern unsere
mangel steg wo wir noch nie geangelt
haben ich habe das damals so vorgestellt
dass wir in den sonnenuntergang angeln
das werde ich jetzt auch zum ende der
heutigen episode mal machen und dass
hier etwas wieder angeln beendet die
heutige episode von daher meine lieben
freunde sage ich jetzt schon mal ganz
kurz wenn es euch heute gefallen hat
meine lieben freunde habe ich hier nicht
irgendwo glück drauf ich habe goethe
einst das ist glaube ich das glück bei
der angel wenns euch heute gefallen
meine lieben freunde tür natürlich zu
machen dann lasst gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da aber nicht
main kanal und klickt auf die glocke
wenn er neue videos nicht verpassen
wollte heute menge geschafft wir haben
den glasboden dahinten hingekriegt bei
der villa wir waren wir wieder bei der
skelett haben da ganz hinten wir haben
ein schweinchen deine ganz hinten geholt
wir haben uns diamant sachen hier unten
gebracht und wir haben den energy water
bucket skill geübt und zudem auch noch
versucht fehlerfall zu verzaubern hat
nicht ganz geklappt aber vielleicht
kriegen was im nächsten vor allem mit
eurem tipps dann und in den kommentaren
also schreibt mir gerne wieder in die
kommentare was ich denn jetzt machen
soll und wir beenden das heutige video
mit dem was ich jetzt angeln werde
[Musik]
eine lehre schüssel